you consider a run for governor of
California then decided against it what
went into each of these decisions and
broadly I should have maybe a selfish
question about Silicon Valley
is it over as a world leader for new
tech companies
as a this Beacon of Promise of
young minds stepping in and creating
something that changes the world
I don't know if those two questions are
connected so it's not it's not over but
I think it's definitely
we're in a challenging moment
because
so back to that analogy of the
demographics if you think about the like
if you bucketed forget like our relative
successes
but there's a bunch of us in this
mid 50s to mid 30s cohort of people that
have now been around you know for 20
years 15 years to 25 years that have
done stuff right
from Andreessen to zoc to Jack Dorsey
Etc Elon you know whatever maybe you
throw me in the mix David sacks whatever
okay
none of us have done a really good job
of becoming a Statesman
um or a States woman you know
um
and really showing a broad empathy and
awareness for the broader systems
so if Silicon Valley is to survive as a
system
we need to know that we've transitioned
from move fast and break things to get
to the right answer and take your time
if that's what it means
and so we have to be a participant of
the system
and I believe that and I think that it's
important to not be a dilettante and not
be thumbing your face to Washington or
not push the boundaries and say you know
we'll deal with it after the fact but to
work with folks that are trying to do
the best again
Steel Man their point of view
you know work with them don't you run
for office so potentially like be you
know understand this
it makes me sad that there's no
tech people or not many tech people in
Congress and certainly not in the
presidential level not many Governors or
Senators well I think that we also have
roughly you know our rules will never
allow some of the best and brightest
folks to run for president because of
just the rules against it but you know
if if Oh you mean yeah yeah I mean like
I think David sacks would be an
incredible presidential candidate now I
also think he'd be a great governor no
he was born in South Africa
you know I think he'd be a great
Governor I think he'd be a great
um Secretary of State I mean he'd be
great at whatever he wanted to do
um you know Friedberg you know wasn't
born here
um so there's there's a lot of people
that could contribute at different
levels and I hope that
by the way the other thing I like about
the Pod is like I also think it helps
normalize Tech a little bit because you
just see like normal people dealing with
normal situations
um and I think that that's good you know
it is a really normative place it's not
the caricature that it's made out to be
but there is a small virul and strain of
people that make it caricature-like
well that's in One Direction what do you
think about the whole
uh culture of
um I don't know if better turns but woke
activism so sort of activism
which in some contexts is a powerful and
important thing but infiltrating
companies I'll answer this in the
context of Renee Gerard so like he says
that people tend to copy each other
and then when they're copying each other
they're really what they're fighting
what they're doing is they're fighting
over some scarce resource
and then you find a way to organize
against you know the group of you
against a person or a thing that you
think is the actual cause of all of this
conflict and you try to expel them
the thing that wokism doesn't understand
is that unless that person is truly to
blame the cycle just continues
and you know that was a that was a
framework that he developed that you
know he's really conclusively proven to
be true and it's observable in humanity
and life
so these movements I think the extreme
left and the extreme right
are trying to interpret away
to allow people to compete for some
scarce resource
but I also think that in all of that
what they don't realize is that they can
scapegoat whoever they want but it's not
going to work because the the Bull Work
of people in the middle realize that
it's just not true
yeah they they realize but they're still
because in leadership positions there's
still momentum and they still scapegoat
and they continue
and it seems to hurt the actual
abilities
In fairness though if you had to graph
the effectiveness of that function it's
decaying rapidly it's the least
effective it's ever been you're
absolutely right being canceled five
years ago was a huge deal
today I think it was Ice Jordan Peterson
on your podcast he said I've been
canceled and it was amazing he said 38
times or 40 he said some number which
was a ginormous number a that he kept
account of it and B was able to classify
it yeah I'm like what classifier is
going on in his mind where he's like Ah
that's an attempt to cancel me but this
one is not but my point is
was clearly not working
and so the guy is still there and the
guy is you know putting his view out
into the world
um and so it's not what not to judge
whether what he says is right or wrong
it's just to observe that this mechanism
mechanism of action is now weakened but
it's weakened because it's not the thing
that people think is really to blame